digamos que tenemos un recipiente lleno
de caramelos y sabemos que hay
exactamente 282 caramelos en ese
recipiente al día siguiente lo vemos y
nos damos cuenta de que hay menos
caramelos y queremos saber qué pasó y
digamos que el amigo que vive con
nosotros nos dice así me comí 59
caramelos y los conté con exactitud
comenzamos con 282 se comieron 59 y no
necesitamos saber exactamente cuántos
caramelos quedan pero queremos estimar
de forma aproximada cuántos caramelos
quedan es por eso que el título de este
vídeo es estimar al restar números
grandes y podemos debatir qué tan grande
es grande pero estos son números
razonablemente grandes vamos a hacerlo
vamos a estimar cuánto es 282 menos 59 a
veces cuando estimamos usamos este signo
de igual ondulado que significa
aproximadamente lo que es una forma
elegante de decir casi igual a lo que
es esto la forma en que yo resolvería
esto es preguntarme si estos números son
cercanos a otros números que sean más
fáciles de restar por ejemplo digamos
que redondeamos 282 a la decena más
cercana así que lo redondeamos a 280 si
lo redondeamos hacia abajo si
redondeamos hacia arriba sería 290 pero
282 está más cerca a 280 que a 290 por
lo que al estimar lo redondeo a 280 y
que hay del 59 si lo redondeo a la
decena más cercana a que lo voy a
redondear pausa en el vídeo y piensen en
ello si redondeo 59 a la decena más
cercana hacia abajo será 50 y si lo
redondeo hacia arriba será 60 sin duda
59 es más cercano a 60 que a 50 así que
digo que esto se aproxima si redondeamos
a 60 puedo decir que 282 menos 51
es aproximadamente igual a 280 menos 60
a que es igual esto seguro pueden hacer
esta operación mentalmente pueden verlo
como 28 decenas menos 6 decenas y si
tenemos 28 de algo y le restamos 6 de
ese algo nos queda 22 de ese algo
podemos decir que esto es
aproximadamente igual a 22 decenas o 220
otra forma de ver esto es decir que
tenemos dos centenas ocho decenas y
vamos a quitar seis decenas de estas
ocho decenas por lo que nos quedan dos
centenas y dos decenas igual a lo que
tenemos aquí el objetivo de esto es que
aunque esto no es exactamente igual a
282 menos 59 si queremos darnos una idea
de aproximadamente cuántos caramelos nos
quedan
esto puede ser útil más adelante verán
que esta es una habilidad muy útil
cuando tenemos números mucho más grandes
que estos pero que al redondear los a la
decena más cercana
a otras posiciones podemos hacer estas
operaciones mentalmente con esto
terminamos